foreign
[Music]
thank you
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
fresh and burn
did Trump hire the driver that's what I
want to know all the online conspiracy
theorists want to know did Donald Trump
hire the driver that crashed Ronda
Santos's campaign car I doubt it
I doubt it I done I mean it sounds like
a good conspiracy theory doesn't it I
don't know
there's a lot of conspiracy theories
going on about Obama's personal chef oh
my gosh
they can't help themselves
when someone has a tragic accident and
drowns in a lake
a family friend a personal chef of
Barack Obama's drowned I believe it's
paddle boarding they were Panner
boarding with other folks too like it's
not some cons Grand conspiracy
but they can't help themselves so why
shouldn't we be able to help ourselves
uh Rhonda Santos apparently is leaving
his State alone again abandoning in his
state to go to Chattanooga Tennessee to
beg people for money because his
campaign just can't get off the ground
poor guy
if he'd just listen to me maybe maybe
he'd be the front runner at this point
if he would have just listened to me but
you know
foreign
who am I to give Republicans campaign
advice
oh my God Rhonda Santa's dude just it's
it's you're not gonna win man you're not
even close you've tried hard you've
spent almost 20 million dollars you're
looking for another 20 million more dude
just give it up it's a cult man and
you're not going to be the cult leader
just just stop it's not it's enough and
you passing racist ass laws in Florida
to act like slavery benefited black
people in this country isn't going to
help either dummy that kind of [__] is
not gonna help you be the president of
the United States you [__] idiot
you're bigoted ass [__] down in in
Florida look listen I I posed the
question this morning we're gonna have
Texas Paul on you know it's Tuesday and
it's Texas Paul
is going to join us I'm gonna ask him
about
his uh disgraced Attorney General of the
State of Texas and their lieutenant
governor apparently the lieutenant
governor has been paid by Ken Paxton
Super PAC three million dollars to make
sure that his impeachment trial goes the
way he wants it wink so I posed the
question this morning who's worse
Texas Republicans or Florida Republicans
boy it's a [__] hot race
speaking of heat God damn it's hot
apparently in in Phoenix Arizona they
have three times as many people going to
the hospital for burns on their body
because they've touched the ground with
their skin holy climate change Batman
that's
oh man
it's wild and crazy out there we're on
indictment launch too right
everyone's on indictment watch the media
is like when is he gonna get indicted
ah they're such chuckleheads the media
that is they're such little heads they
they know what the indictment's gonna be
about it's going to be about January 6th
they know who's going to bring the
indictment they know who is the indictee
at the top of the food chain they
understand this stuff but they still
can't help themselves
they still can't Ponder when the exact
moment he'll be indicted as if it
matters
it's not listen to me it's not going to
matter as far as his campaign goes
they're not going to they're not going
to walk away from him this is only going
to empower him more in his campaign
because it's a
cult it's a cult it's a [__]
cult
hmm and until you understand that really
come to grips with it you won't quite
understand why they stay with him
Mitt Romney apparently um talking about
hot dogs and how they should I'm not
kidding you I think he said the hot dogs
were the best meat ever I'm not saying
that's not the truth but it sounds a
little far-fetched that hot dogs are the
greatest meat ever in the history of
meat but here's the thing Mitt Romney
also he's a meathead he's ate way too
many [__] hot dogs and the reason why
is because Mitt Romney thinks
that somehow Donald Trump's gonna take a
pledge to drop out in February if if
another candidate emerges and wins
delegates Mitt Romney don't you see what
you're doing dummy
you're you're encouraging all the other
and all the other
candidates to drop out when Trump
swipes the floor with them with
delegates you dumbass he's gonna take
every [__] one of them people every
last one of them I don't know I don't
know how many times I have to say it I
know how clear I have to be I don't know
why why this country the right the left
the center the independent still are in
a wild delusion that he's not somehow
there's gonna be someone come out of
nowhere and be the Republican nominee
this is all nonsense
it's all [__] the only way we have a
different Republican nominee than Trump
next year during the general election is
if the guy accidentally chokes on a Big
Mac
and dies before he hits the ground now
I'm not saying I advocate for that but
hey I'm on the side of a Big Mac in that
case but the problem is is that this
delusion
people stop it stop the delusion stop
the [__] he is going to be their
nominee
now what we have to figure out in the
meantime and how to politicize every
single goddamn issue so we can win up
and down the ballot in every single
state that's the that's the point Jesus
Christ if you're not watching what's
going on in these states like Florida
and Texas you don't know the
consequences of not participating in
your democracy
it's so important
it's so important to participate in your
democracy
that's why on my patreon we're going to
start what we're calling right now the
round table of democracy
it's gonna be like uh democracy and
training type stuff we're going to bring
people on we're gonna have round tables
I'm gonna present the the the the video
content that we produce the interviews
and the training and the tutorials the
workshops everything that we have guests
on to do on my patreon I will present it
to the public the patreon just get for
that first access they get to come to
the live chat
some of them will probably appear on
screen even
but we're gonna do this so today I ask
you I ask you to to start this this
round table of democracy right here on
the Tony Michaels podcast
what we should do is phone a bonehead
that was one of the ideas that came out
of the patreon meeting on Sunday phone a
bonehead and our phone of bonehead today
should be Tommy tuberville we're going
to talk about that more today about
phoning a bonehead
we got to get engaged in our democracy
we have to we're gonna have to we're
gonna have to win in 2024 and not just
at the top of the ticket we've had just
Piper on we've had Dr Rachel bidikoffer
on they told you about strategy they
told you why these State races are so
important
we we see why they're so important I
mean Greg Abbott Greg Abbott today
basically giving the middle finger to
the federal government saying I don't
give a [__] if we're drowning women and
children that's what I want and that's
what I'm gonna do I'll take my right to
kill migrants coming across the border
to seek American Life a better life a
free life day each say they believe in
freedom but do they because Greg Abbott
wants to drown them in Snag and drown
buoys coming across the river and if
they make it across the river by God he
wants to capture him and raise her wire
what a piece of [__] bio-human trash
Greg Abbott is
it's not surprising that their
lieutenant governor
is bought and paid for three million
dollars by their sick ass [__]
disgraced attorney general Ken Paxton
Texas Republicans seem to be some of the
worst in the country but are they really
are they really the worst or is it just
all of them this way hmm I guess we'll
find out soon enough
hmm
oh boy I kind of dunked on myself didn't
I there we're only 12 minutes into the
show and I just oh man I'm on fire and I
just ran down the court and dunked the
ball
there's a whole half a game left oh
speaking of basketball games apparently
LeBron James son brawny I think is what
they call him I'm not really sure I'm
not much of a LeBron James fan or
basketball fan anymore I used to be when
uh in the 90s but I don't watch much
basketball anymore but apparently he's
had some sort of cardiac event on the
court apparently he's stable doing fine
I guess so I'm not sure the exact
reports but of course of course the
right wing jumps all over this story
in the vaccinations conspiracy theory
already I don't know RFK Jr is probably
on some dumbass podcast already talking
about it already saying crazy ass frogs
turn gay type [__]
he does he thinks frogs are turning as
gay or something or RFK Jr I I don't
know he's like Alex it's as if Alex
Jones Steve Bannon and Roger Stone
[__] and had a baby and that's how you
get RFK Jr
I'm serious I'm serious what do you want
from me
I again I don't get to make this [__] up
I just get to tell you about it
but the day online on Twitter on X which
is another goddamn story oh [__] you're
not gonna believe this
but on Twitter this morning
the vaccine conspiracy theorists are all
over this brawny story and listen folks
in a heat wave
and when when it's a thousand degrees
on the ground when you're getting when
you're getting third degree burns
because you touch the earth I would say
we're gonna have a lot more emergency
events in this country it's gonna happen
it's hot hot hot hot hotter than a
[__] out there so be careful
drink water stay cool super important
heat stroke is nothing to [__] with
it certainly something that is terrible
for your health and it doesn't matter
how old you are how fit you are you can
succumb to heat stroke very quickly
without even realizing it
so be careful be safe out there as it is
hot hot hot speaking of Twitter
and the conspiracy theorists and right
Wingers on Twitter did you hear this
oh Elon you are such a stupid [__]
good Lord listen last year when he
bought it
I really I really
um thought it would be funny if he did
and the reason why is because it truly
would show who he is and I tried to tell
him then last year when he was going
through this process to just do the
buyout and don't
don't buy the son of a [__] just pay
the [__] fine get out of the contract
walk away from it Elon it's not gonna
work you're an idiot
I was right of course he's an idiot of
course it's the biggest stain on Elon on
his reputation of being the smartest man
ever which he's not even close
to being smart let alone the smartest
man ever and yesterday proved it when he
decided that he was going to switch The
Branding from Twitter to X now not only
did they stop him in San Francisco so
they they rent a they rent a lift truck
a bucket truck
to take the [__] name off the the
building to put an X up on the building
and true Nazi fashion I don't know if
you know this but not X is like a is
like a symbol for fashion
that's why no one would call their
social media platform X by the way but
you know
who who Who's who's claiming Elon knows
anything about [__] Nuance but
they're taking the Twitter name off the
building right to put an X up there
I had no [__] permits to do this of
course he had no permission to do this
he probably didn't even know you have to
have permission to do this because he
lives in [__] la la billionaire land
which they don't know [__] they don't
have respect for other they are on
respect for the law they don't respect
for the process they think they can do
whatever the [__] whenever they want
because they got money and they're white
that's the way he thinks what do you
want he's apartheid baby what do you
want from me I I don't make again I
don't get to make this [__] up I just
come here and tell you what the hell is
going on
but yesterday the the San Francisco
Police Department stopped him in his
tracks of even putting the X upon his
building because he failed to have
enough staff with enough brain cells to
rub together to know that hey if we're
gonna change something on the building
we're probably gonna have to have a
permit and if we're gonna have a lift
truck out here on the sidewalk
and a in a construction crew we might
need a permit here in the city of San
Francisco it might might be a thing
what a [__] idiot
well even more idiotic than him not
getting a permit for taking the name out
the building
Elon Musk
didn't even have the foresight to make
sure that he could even name
Twitter X and use x
as the name of Twitter and the reason
why is because Microsoft apparently owns
the the trademark to X and meta
Facebook Mark Zuckerberg owns the
trademark to X4 social media what a
stupid bastard apparently Microsoft's
trademark is for banking and that's been
Elon Musk is stupid delusional plan the
whole time
he's been talking about having an app
very similar to WeChat in China
where it's an everything app where they
get to spy on you for everything that
you do including your banking
that's right that's what Elon Musk wants
to do hmm if you know what it feels like
to me it feels like to me we shouldn't
be giving our bank account information
to a guy who's in Hawk for uh for a
social media website that he doesn't own
the trademark to anymore because he
renamed it to someone else's trademark
also that he's in haunt to to Saudi
Arabia for 44 billion dollars and
growing every day with interest
wow the goddamn website isn't even worth
third that value it just feels like to
me you wouldn't give that guy your
banking information what do you think
Jesus Christ what is what is wrong with
these [__] Elon simps how do they not
see now right out in the open that this
guy doesn't need to have the kind of
money he has we should have a stupid tax
I mean I want to tax the rich certainly
absolutely let's tax them into Oblivion
[__] them they don't need this much
money
if you can if you can afford to buy
whatever social media site you want
and then change the name and do all this
[__] ah you can afford taxes but we
should also have a stupid tax you know
what I mean when you do really stupid
[__] with money I mean really stupid
[__] with money we should just tax the
[__] out of you especially if you have
any left over [__] them I
Eat the Rich eat the stupid that's what
I feel like you know oh Tony you you
can't do that well I can say it can I
I can say it if I want to oh boy
I tell you what
this world is getting dumber and dumber
and dumber
I watched a we watched a clip
um um let's see was it yesterday or the
day before we watched well we watched
several Jason Aldean Clips
um but yesterday we saw someone stuff
him in the trash for running today I'm
going to show you a little stand up from
Trey Crowder I think it's worth it's
worth noting uh that Trey Crowder would
talk about Jason Aldean and the reason
why is because Trey Crowder is from uh
what do you call it a small town
maybe we should go to more small town
people to see what the [__] they think
about Jason Aldean
you know I I I don't know I I
still debating rather I want to show you
a Jason Aldean standing on stage whining
and crying about how he's being canceled
poor [__] guy
but this Jason Aldean story just won't
go away and the reason why is because
it's so hilarious to laugh at him
yeah
it's so hilarious to laugh at him it
really is it's the same reason why the
Ben Shapiro Barbie thing isn't going
away it's so fun to laugh at them
they're such [__] fragile fascist
snowflakes aren't they Jesus Christ
you [__] people are just frail why
how how in the world did the [__] your
feelings crowd get so goddamn weak oh
that's right it's all [__] and
projection every single time
and some have asked we had we had
Tennessee Brando on yesterday and we
talked about this extensively about uh
not not only Jason Aldean but the
history of country music
and I and I know I I know I keep
pounding the subject with Jason Aldean
but folks this story is not just the
only story in this narrative I mean we
go back to the Kid Rock shooting a Bud
Light because Dylan Mulvaney did one
Instagram post with a beer in her hand
and they freaked the [__] out they
thought a beer was gonna turn him gay do
you know that Bud Light is
quintessential American Beer it is the
first it is the first national beer that
we had
America first right unless you know
Dylan Mulvaney holds a beer and drinks
it in an Instagram post
there's such a bunch of [__] [__]
every last one of them
and it's it's crazy to me because I've
been watching post because I live in
Trump land right I know a lot of stupid
[__] white people just because of my
experience in life Texas Paul can tell
you about this today too I'm sure with
this Jason Aldean [__]
but I I see plenty of people that I know
personally posting on social media about
how [__] [__] [__] is worse for our
culture than Jason Aldean you're telling
you're telling me women getting horny
and wet and wanting sex is worse than
[__] murdering black people that come
to your town because you don't like them
what the [__] are you talking about and
who the [__] in the city is going to
small towns they're not going to small
towns
frankly when Jason Aldean holds a
concert he doesn't hold it in a small
town
when the [__] was the last time Jason
Aldean went to a small town of 500 and
held a concert it didn't happen
you know where they hold these concerts
do you know where Jason Aldean booked
his concerts at not in a [__] small
town
no not in a small town in a big city and
guess what those small town people do
they go to the big city
so maybe we should have a song try that
in a big city you [__] hick maybe
that's what we should do I don't know
maybe that is the case
but it seems like it almost feels like
that Jason Aldean and all his broke
country eat boys as we as we heard
Tennessee Brando brand them yesterday
bro country
I like that by the way branding them bro
country I'm really into that
it really describes him well you know
these [__] types
these guys that never have never touched
a hay bale net never never did cattle
work in their [__] life never
butchered a goddamn chicken
not a one not a one never went fishing
never went frog gigging in their [__]
life never had to shoot a possum because
they were eating their [__] chicken
eggs never in their life done any of
that wearing cowboy boots Bejeweled
jeans and a and a trump shirt and a
cowboy hat you [__]
take the cowboy hat off [__] you're not
no [__] Cowboy never was never have
been Jason Aldean you're a [__] poser
just like your [__] fans every last
one of them and that's what they're
writing these songs for
that's why he's getting the support of
all the Bro country singers
is because that's that's that's their
fan base they've written these songs
specifically for those those white dudes
and their stupid [__] white
girlfriends that's right I said it
I don't give a [__] what you think
Jason Aldean wrote this song produced
that video and whining and crying online
to his [__] broke country ye eat boys
his fans about this song
and it's ridiculous
number one objectively again it's not
even a good song it sucks it's horrible
it's not it doesn't have a catchy tune
it doesn't have catchy lyrics at all it
just says oh hey come come here
we'll shoot you up you come in our town
we don't like you because we're we're
we're rednecks or some [__] like that
listen there's nothing wrong with being
proud of being a hillbilly or redneck or
a hick
God damn it's a way of life in some
parts of this country
but as Tennessee Brando told you
yesterday this is not the brand of like
Appalachia
no it is not
it is not the brand of downtrodden white
people in this country that's not the
brand and that's the opposite you
wouldn't be defending the police when I
grew up where I'm from which is in the
Lake of the Ozarks in Missouri which is
the hillbilly now if you had to I don't
live in Appalachia but I didn't grow up
in Appalachia but if you had to pick out
a part of Missouri that resembles
Appalachia it would definitely be the
Lake of the Ozarks instead of moonshine
we have meth
like uh they do moonshine in Appalachia
we do meth
where I'm from uh what do you want then
again I don't get to make this [__] up I
just report to you but here's the thing
here's the thing nowhere when I grew up
did anyone like the [__] cops no one
no one liked the [__] cops what's
this back to Blue [__] what's this [__]
in this video where they're they're
backing the blue and taking and taking
cuts of protest overseas and [__] huh it
it's almost like it's almost like
they're full of [__] it's almost like
the entire thing is for manga
do you think there's a bunch of Joe
Biden supporters going to Jason Aldean
concerts do you think there's a bunch of
people who want women to have their
right to their health care going to a
bunch of Jason Aldean concerts
huh do you think do you think that
people who want sensible [__] gun
control so children aren't shot up in
rural schools because that's where the
school shootings happen is in these
small towns Jason Aldean Uvaldi is a
small [__] town
I bet I bet Jason Aldean couldn't find
Uvalde on the [__] map if his life
depended on it
but you're not gonna find these people
at these Aldine concerts no no you're
not gonna find these people buying his
records they're not gonna find these
people paying 99 Cents for that pile of
[__] on Apple no
you're not
it's only the worst of us
speaking of the worst of us it's the
same people who are cheering the fact
that in Florida they want to teach that
slavery was good for black people
they're cheering that Greg Abbott is
drowning families coming across the
border in the river and he's willing to
take it to the Supreme Court for his
right to drown him you say pro-life I
say [__] you that's what I say to the
Republican party and if you want to hear
more of it every single weekday do not
forget right now to subscribe to the
Tony Michaels podcast here on YouTube
click the like button down below make
sure to hit the like I don't know I'm
not very good at YouTube
they should have like a pop-up Bing oh
hit the like button it'll be awesome or
you can hit the dislike button I don't
give a [__] hit that one too go for it
go for it just engage that's all I care
get it get in the chat get in the
comments hate me hate hate us whatever
you want to do let's do it let's do it
let's do it because we got Texas Paul
today because it's Tuesday Tuesday July
25th
I'm super excited about today uh because
um I I am going to show I I don't think
me in Texas Paul I've had a chance to
really talk about Jason Aldean I don't
think so I'm really excited to hear him
Texas but I know he's had he's had a few
things to see about this you know Texas
Paul
it's from a place where he can wear a
cowboy hat
and no one thinks he's a poser because
he's not Jason Aldean's Cowboy aunt is a
poser and I want to show I want to show
Texas and Texas Paul a great picture of
Jason Aldean and he can tell me about
his manly Hood it looks like a cheese
curd Bud to me but we're gonna we're
gonna we're gonna take a look at that
and then we're gonna see him trick
router I also want to talk to Texas Paul
today about what the hell is going on
with Texas Republicans and why why is
his lieutenant governor why is he
lieutenant governor taking three million
dollars from Ken Paxton their disgraced
attorney general who's about to be
impeached when the lieutenant governor
is the one who presides over his trial
hmm seems kind of fishy to me I don't
know seems about as fishy as snagging
drown buoys in a river to drown families
seems kind of fishy just like it seems
kind of fishy in Florida
to both sides slavery don't go anywhere
Texas poll when we come right back right
after this
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott finder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around through the
break the break break break free we got
Texas fall in the waiting room you know
it's Tuesday it's Taco Tuesday Texas
Palm Tuesday always always excited
Texas Paul Stakes on the news
it's been a week since we talked to him
here on the Tony Michaels podcast
so I want to get a take on Jason Aldean
but Texas Republicans are in the
Forefront in the news this morning
because Greg Abbott says you know what I
want to be able to drown I want to be
able to drown women and children not
only that if they make it past the
snagging around buoys I want to make
sure I capture them in razor wire on the
shores of the river that way that way we
can really bang them up you know
pro-life type stuff right Texas polling
that right this is poor light type stuff
am I am I right or am I right
he's such a freaking [__] bag I I mean
he really is that there is just no other
way to describe this sorry
colostomy bag of a human being he is
just
I mean we're not at war with these
people Tony these are our allies you
don't put razor wire up at the border
with your allies
you know they they [__] us and keep
us from fixing the immigration system we
can't even get enough immigrants
processed
to satisfy our own work requirements
you know we can't we can't even just
take care of ourselves with this broken
ass immigration system but they won't
let us fix it because they want the
talking point they want the crisis and
then instead of letting us take care of
it they try to put up a
thousand-year-old wall I mean there's a
thousand-year-old freaking technology
we've got seismic said Tony we have
seismic sensors that are so advanced
they can communicate with satellites
they can track how many people are
walking they could track how fast you're
walking they can track out the direction
you're walking
they can give an exact GPS coordinate on
you
you know that that's that's what
Democrats do technology man technology
we don't go way stuff a [__] ton of
money pardon my life I'm a little pissed
off sorry man now go ahead and go ahead
you're on the attorney Michael's bike
games you can say whatever the hell you
want I grew up in South Texas Tony yeah
I grew up in South Texas I don't see
these people and I don't I don't have
fear in my heart I I see my neighbors I
see my friends
you know these are not our freaking
enemies you get some fat pasty piece of
[__] up here in North Texas that that's
like oh they're gonna they're gonna come
across and commit crime they're gonna
come across and and bring drugs well you
know you know how the drug dealers get
across Tony
all right when the Republican when the
Republicans you know kept title 42 in
place right which was basically a free
pass which caused all of that illegal
immigration the drug dealers just walked
in the crowd
but when you have a real immigration
policy where you don't have a lot of
people crossing illegally like we
Democrats do I mean illegal immigrations
drops over 70 percent now right the
border crossings have plummeted the
amount and and you would think Greg
Abbott would think that they've doubled
by putting up these these snagging
drowns and they're called that they
actually that's not the official name of
them but they call them snag and drowns
in other words so I don't know if people
know this and maybe you can describe it
a little better but a lot of people
don't understand that the river there
some points of the river the water is
only a couple feet high right two three
feet high right and right now it's even
lower because there's just not any
[__] water so goddamn hot so these
buoys sit damn near on the riverbed
right there may be only a foot of water
below these buoys and you have to either
climb above them climb between them or
go underneath them which is almost
impossible without getting snagged on
them right I mean that's the whole point
now what what is crazy right now because
the river's down is a lot of folks are
just going to a more a deeper part of
the river and swimming across which is
way more risk for drowning because
they're going outside these buoys so
what Greg Abbott is doing isn't stopping
people from Crossing that is not what is
happening well his his idea that here
that this deters people from Crossing is
all a bunch of [__] it does not
deter people from Crossing they're
they're so desperate to become part of
America that they are willing to risk
their lives going across this River and
Greg Abbott is doing his damnedest to
kill them while crossing this River he's
doing his damnness and and the thing is
is that that it's not only that that he
on this this morning is like yeah you
goddamn right we're gonna drown him
we'll take it all the way to Supreme
Court for our right to do so and and not
so many words but that's what he [__]
means that's what he [__] means it's
even worse Tony it's even worse there's
1254 miles right of Texas Mexican border
buoys there's 1 000 yards of buoys in
the Rio Grande Christ
and they put them in a place where
people cross
it on purpose to have a spectacle on
camera to get the doj to tell them
because the state has no no right
whatsoever to build a border barrier no
it's not it's not their Waterway it's a
federal Waterway exactly exactly and
they've been told to remove them but the
whole point of it is it isn't to stop
immigration it's not
I mean there's
1254 miles of freaking border this is a
thousand yards worth of buoys it is a
photo op is all it is it is intentional
cruelty at a spot where they can film
intentional cruelty these Republicans
want this they want people hurt they
wanted that story to come out where they
were shoving children back in the river
because they're voters their piece of
garbage crap human being I'm pro-life
voters want that cruelty it's a fixture
not a bug in the system it's a fixture
that's right well in Captain says
cruelty is the point and I I've been
saying that the this is all their
policies the cruelty is the point and
they want the Uproar they want the
outrage over the cruelty right just like
what you're saying and the reason why is
because if if people get upset if
reasonable people get upset seeing
videos of women and children being
drowned in the river because they're
trying to cross it to come here to be to
be something better to live the American
dream as we call it right
to migrate to this country from a place
where they might die that their lives
are in danger in the first place so
they're willing to risk their lives to
come to America and we put we put we put
dangerous deadly obstacles in their way
to do that
that's inhumane it takes away their
Humanity but not only that the the
actual images and the videos of this
stuff to piss people off it Hypes these
these [__] idiots up and and and to
believe to believe that somehow this is
a serious political movement
again folks we have fascists at our
front door and they're using imagery of
killing women and children crossing a
river to come to America to have a
better life because we as liberals
believe that America if you come here
from another country that where you're
where you're oppressed or about to be
killed or being trafficked We Believe
coming here you could have a better life
and yeah America isn't easy everyone
knows that especially if you come here
from another country if you migrate here
it's not easy
life is a [__] it is it's hard it's
hard but it's worth it and they they do
this all to own the libs that's all it
is the cruelty is the point to own the
libs because they want us to be outraged
they love that we're outraged that
they're killing women and children they
love it they absolutely love it Texas
Paul
that that is 100 true they want this
fight they do because they want to be
seen as being cruel but then on top of
it they want the ability to abuse these
people they don't want the immigration
system fixed where they can come through
and get a work permit or whatever I had
a conversation with a couple just three
days ago Laura and I were sitting there
talking to to these folks they're both
here illegally they were quite open
about it
uh the wife had been here for 20 years
she is taking care of she's a
housekeeper and has taken care of
elderly Americans hurt for 20 years she
they have five children here
they've lived the American dream but we
have treated them as second class people
we've treated them like crap her husband
has worked construction for 30 years
Tony you know how hard that is on a man
I mean he has worked construction for 30
years and his boss knows he does the
work of five Americans
he does he busts his ass but we're
telling them you cannot they've spent
she alone has spent nine thousand
dollars on the process to to become
legal but there's so many hitches and
pitfalls in the stupid system she's got
to have a relative that lives here and
now the way the law set up she has to
leave go back to Mexico she's lived here
for 20 years who where is she gonna go
what ties does she have in Mexico after
living here for 20 years you know she's
got to go back to Mexico to reapply
which is going to be another 14 to 16
year process Tony
yeah she's lived here paid taxes her
entire time she's paid taxes paid into
Social Security and Medicare
you know and and done nothing but take
care of us
and we need more of her Tony we do we
don't have the workforce to maintain you
know the society has got to be a pyramid
it has to be there have to be more
people at the bottom working taking care
of the people at the top and we're right
now we're turning into a square because
there's so many old people and not
enough workers we need them Tony
and we treat them like crap
you know how about showing them some
respect
you know I mean how about showing
somebody that will go out there and bust
their ass and 100 degree heat to build
your houses and you know these these
rednecks that love this Trump [__]
the minute they've got a fence to put up
or something will go down to freaking
Home Depot and hire a truckload of these
guys
they'll do it in a minute man
well of course they will labor well you
know you bring up a good point here
and I want to tell you that the the
people who are excited that
um Greg Abbott is killing women and
children at the border on purpose he
knows that's what he's doing that's the
whole and that's the whole point of it
is to kill women and children at the
border to drown them in the river to
have the the images to fire up his 10 15
of the country that is the Maga base
it's the same [__] cheering on
Jason Aldean same [__] same
same if you're if you're like Jesus
Christ they're doing what at the Texas
border in the river where these people
across they're trying to drown them
you're probably like yeah [__] Jason
Aldean he's a racist
that's it's probably the same and I I I
I I know I know it feels like that the
Jason Aldean thing isn't relevant
but the he's not relevant their fans
aren't relevant the sentiment is
relevant and the reason why it's
relevant is because we need to keep
pounding at this that these people are
awful [__] they're amongst us
yes they are it it takes a lot it takes
a while it takes a long time to shame
these people into this [__]
and if you don't believe me just go back
in history go back to the civil rights
movement and watch just watch videos of
people of people protesting
that
and and calling for more segregation
as George Wallace went on his campaign
of segregation then segregation now
segregation forever
and just look at those [__] white
people and the cruelty what's the point
it was the point the cruelty was the
point and they they would feel the same
way when they would hold the same signs
today if we were in that situation so
you better damn better believe Jason
Aldean and all these other racist
country music artists because they're
not all racist I'm sick of that [__] too
I talked to that yesterday with
Tennessee Brando country music isn't
rooted in racism it's rooted in folk
music
and these [__] these [__] have
hijacked with bro country
hijacked Nashville and this [__]
country music scene it's ridiculous it's
absolutely ridiculous the latest Trend
that's coming out of country music is
country rap right the rap country themes
country songs but rapping that's the
latest Trend that's coming geez where
did that come from I don't know I don't
know where they would get appropriate
rap from that I mean
frankly white people appropriate all
black culture and that's just how it
goes in this country and that's how we
got to do American culture in the first
place
I've got another good friend you know
you know Tennessee Brando is a good
friend of mine I love that guy he is
he's got a great heart I got another
good friend of mine he's also a great
guy but he's just taking the wrong tack
on this he really has he's like this was
a poor business decision is what it was
he didn't write the song it was a poor
business decision to do the song by
Jason Aldean subculture yeah he was
trying to sell to a certain subculture
no it's a great business decision for
Jason Aldean don't you think
mm-hmm not long run it's not well I mean
I understand but who else who else is
Jason Aldean gonna Pander to do you
think I okay I got a guy here and
waiting in the wings who isn't a country
music fan and my my guess is is that no
matter what songs Jason Aldean put out
he wouldn't buy Jason Aldean's song Gabe
Sanchez joined I bought the whole
discography man that's [__]
I would no I mean like I you never knew
Jason Aldean was before this [__] yeah
man I thought his name was James look I
don't know who the guy is and I don't
care to know but I also think it's a
piece of [__] but that's my point Paul
is that it was a good business decision
for him in this moment because that's
what these idiots think about they only
think about this moment right in front
of your face right it's the same thing
he's screwed well right but it's the
same reason why Elon it's the same
reason why Elon makes the decisions that
he makes it's because he's trying to
placate to his fan base and his fan base
is absolute [__] they don't understand
like a lot of time times a lot of times
when you're creating content and we're
all three content creators here I guess
I guess she calls that we're I'm a
podcaster I don't know if I'm a content
creator I just I'm a commentator right
that's right I I consider myself a
commentator but we create content but
the thing is is that you know sometimes
in content creation you have two
different ways you can do it you can
either Pander to an audience or you can
you can try to talk to the audience that
you want right like that state that
sometimes that's the two choices you
have when you're making content when you
make a piece and Gabe Sanchez can speak
to this he makes long pieces where he's
writing it he's producing it and me and
me and Texas Paul just kind of talking
to the camera right I mean we just ran
into the camera
that's only because I'm like finding
little Clips or little memes you guys I
mean more prop too to flow off the Dome
I just got to write it all to know
exactly how the jokes and the
information is going to flow but in
terms of Jason Aldean like
it's the same strategy that Republicans
have used before they don't they do not
future proof their ideas and they think
in the present the right there you go
can I
say what I want to say and no issues
there right do I want to slap a sticker
on a on a on a gas tank and say I did
that and not have the foresight to think
well maybe gas price will go down and if
that sticker is on there long enough
it's gonna look like Joe Biden actually
brought the prices down and you look at
inflation jobs anything across the board
Republicans do not have the tenant they
do not have the ability to say oh man if
I say this right now is this going to
bite me in the ass later on and they
just they they are unable unable and
unwilling to accept this despite the
fact that every time it happens it's the
same outcome they always get the rake in
the face and they try it again
exactly what you're saying is why I'm
saying Jason Aldean is screwed going
forward because there are some things
Tony what you were talking about about
decisions that have to be made and if
you're going after an audience you may
lose a bit of another audience and
you've got to make a choice about what
you say and do
but you're Guided by who you are inside
and Jason Aldean chose the Maury County
courthouse on
purpose he knew that was a dog whistle
to the right to to the white
supremacists he knew that was straight
up racist he knew that was the site of
the lynching of Henry Choate and he did
it on purpose to say yeah you know
because there's that whole right wing we
can be as awful as we want to be and you
can't do a damn thing about it mentality
he did exactly what you're talking about
Tony he went out there and he said yeah
I'm going to try to get that audience
but he screwed himself because what Gabe
was saying he had no idea the rest of us
knew who the hell Henry Choate was he
had no idea that you and I would sit
here and explain Henry Choate was a man
that was falsely accused of attacking a
white woman he was convicted by a dog
literally a dog was the evidence they
used a bloodhound followed a trail to
his grandpappy's house where he was just
visiting
and you know how white dogs work Tony
that dog is not you know no Southern
Sheriff went through and trained a
freaking Bloodhound to actually be a
well-trained bloodhound they they made
white dogs out of them is what they did
and he because his Bloodhound went to
this house they locked him in jail then
250 white boys showed up
I say white boys there were women there
too they drug him out of they threatened
the sheriff's wife they drug him out of
the cell they hit him with a hammer they
tied him to the back of a car
drug him around town while he was alive
people
and then took him to the courthouse and
strung him up by his neck till he died
and that is what Jason Aldean chose to
put as a spectacle in his music video
that is not a poor business decision
that is a poor human being that is a
shitty human being right there he
thought he was going to Pander do it
exactly what you were talking about Tony
he was going to Pander that crowd that
his we can be as awful as we want to be
and there's nothing you can do about it
well guess what folks his career
he's marginalized into that one little
freaking extreme group forever I oh yeah
I totally believe that but you know
here's the thing folks until until we
until if we don't keep pushing back on
this [__] he'll have an audience
that he can sell out and these Stu and
just like I said in the intro these
stupid [__] bro country eat boys will
drive from their small towns to the big
cities to pay Jason Aldean money to sing
if you try that in a small town why
they're in a big city from a [__]
small town it's [__] crazy and
ridiculous but he's gonna have an
audience and that's what they know
that's what Kid Rock knows that's that's
what [__] that's what Blake Shelton
knows that's what uh uh who else is
supporting Luke Bryant that's what they
know uh Morgan Wallen that's what they
know they know that that's their
audience because they can't do the other
thing they can't say you know what Jason
Aldean is a [__] racist piece of [__]
I condemn this this isn't what country
music is and Jason Aldean should be
ashamed of himself and no one should buy
a [__] Jason Aldean ticket because
Luke Bryan can't say that because the
[__] people who buy tickets from
Jason Aldean are the same [__]
you buy Luke Bryan tickets
that's just it man that's just it and if
you don't like it get on your [__]
Facebook and look at the people saying
the [__] about art support Jason Aldean
I had someone I had someone that I
couldn't believe I couldn't believe they
posted some kind of [__] meme about
how [__] is destroying our country wet
ass [__] the song find cardi B is
ruining our country but Jason Aldean is
making it stronger
somehow the fabric of our country is
torn apart because women get horny for
sex which is a human thing but oh boy
it's really good for the fabric of our
country when white people are singing
songs about Sundown towns and killing
black people that come to their towns
yeah okay yeah that's right
can I throw something out there yeah go
ahead okay
this is what they what they do on the
right is they will take and they'll take
the lyrics of and try that in a small
town and if you just look at the lyrics
alone it's really not that horrific
right I mean we know it's Fantasyland
[__] but it's filled with those
freaking dog whistles
racism but the minute you call them out
on the intentional racism they pretend
that doesn't exist and then they're
gonna go find a rap song that is
intentionally raunchy
I mean they put the song out to be
raunchy they didn't hide it they don't
apologize for it they don't apologize
for it today they say if you want to
hear that listen to it if you don't want
to hear that don't listen to it it is
not played on the radio it is not played
on the radio
but this racist asked Anthem this white
grievance Anthem will be played on the
radio and they will sit there and they
will they will dissect these two songs
together and try to say look how awful
they are they want to listen to wet ass
[__] but they don't want you to listen
to try that in a small town when you're
just talking about your heritage look at
the lyrics see the lyrics don't say
anything about murdering black black
folks but we know what the freaking dog
whistles are we know what you were
trying to say and we know you're like a
freaking faint you know frail ass
weak sorry individual with no no spine
to back up your convictions you wanted
the giddiness of saying oh yeah we're
going to be racist and we're going to be
awful but the minute you got called out
on it it's like we didn't say that
you're just being mean to us you know I
mean if you're gonna if you're gonna
write lyrics If You're Gonna Write those
lyrics and you're gonna you know put a
together a montage of specifically
chosen video
that incite a specific emotion some of
it not even from this country yeah yeah
and specifically from a group that you
want right this this group of of
broke Country Boys country that's what
I'm calling whatever it is right you you
wrote a song
you matched that song with specific
footage because you wanted to prove your
point even more
that your song was exactly what it was a
racist piece of [__] a trash song and
then going back to Tony's point is
when you have these other country
singers who don't say anything
right they're either silent or they back
and say you misinterpreted the song it's
not racist despite the imagery despite
the messaging it's not racist
they have also decided to put themselves
in that corner it's I don't know what
the demographic is of country music fans
an audience in the United States but I
have to imagine that the the type of
audience within the country music
demographic
is much smaller
than the larger population specifically
to this this type of of Music this type
of racist music and the fact that uh
there are these larger musicians who
either are being silent you know they're
complicit right it's like when you when
you've got 10 Nazis at a table and
you're sitting at the table there's 11
Nazis you've got 10 races sitting at a
table or ten racist country singers or
whatever and you're sitting at that
table you don't say anything
you're also either the fan of country
racist music or or a fellow musician who
is also a racist country singer
and and well go ahead go ahead no I mean
the the point I'm trying to make here is
like these people who are either silent
or have spoken out in defense
of Jason Aldean are going to find
themselves in the same boat because now
they're splitting there instead of being
like hey you know what we're going to
talk about everyday living I'm a country
boy this and this and that whatever it
might be that's more of like a general
message to everyone you can relate
because this is the same lifestyle but
as soon as you go specific into the
imagery and the type of text and
narrative that you're trying to push and
then you defend the person that made
that you now are in that same camp which
means I would guarantee that there's
going to be a a chunk of that that
audience that you have now lost forever
right and going back to what what Texas
ball said well I'll tell you that the
history of country music isn't rooted in
racism it's actually reading in folk
music and it's actually rooted in the uh
the plight of poor wine Appalachia uh is
where it's rooted and then and then and
then it came to uh Nashville and Memphis
and I don't know if you know anything
about Memphis but the there's the Blues
in Memphis and when the blues paired
with folk music that's what really
birthed modern country music we saw it
with Elvis even crossing over into
calling it rock and roll which um the
blues and and Black Culture delivered us
rock and roll in this country and of
course white people appropriate
immediately because it's [__] awesome
and not only the country music blues and
rock and roll but it's awesome but these
people don't have enough [__] Nuance
to go back and look at what the history
of country music is or the matriarchs
and Patriarchs of country music Willie
Nelson Willie Nelson did a little set
and he basically said Jason Aldean has
his head up his ass by singing a song
and I almost guaran goddamn tea that
Dolly Parton would never would never
[__] stand on the side of Jason
Aldean and I believe that country music
has a come to Jesus moment here uh in
the next in the next decade or two
because you have artists like Chris
Stapleton who is not a [__] racist
who does not sing racist songs who Who
as a matter of fact Chris Stapleton
admits he knows where his Soulful voice
comes from black people
he knows it he knows it he knows where
his music comes from he knows where his
the the the the the voice of his art
comes from he understands the history of
country music Jason Aldean is a [__]
poser he's not a country music artist he
pretends to be just like [__] Kid
Rock pretends to be some country [__]
music artist when that piece of garbage
is from Detroit some rich kid from
Detroit who was a rapper in the 90s who
rebranded himself because he couldn't
get any other [__] any other [__]
show any other booking but on a hate
stage with Donald Trump the same as Ted
Nugent
so Jason Aldean will be will be cascaded
in the crowd that will only it will only
be booked for hate rallies eventually
but it is up to us it is up to the
people to keep pressing on this because
his culture is [__] stupid and it's
it's delusional and it's a stupid
alternative narrative that really
doesn't even really exist if you listen
to the lyrics of the song the song
doesn't even describe a small town let
me show you let me show you a little bit
of Comedy because here is real art from
Trey Crowder a lot of people know him as
the liberal redneck everyone knows that
Trey Crowder is from a small town
and that he knows probably a thing or
two about [__] country music like I
do I I grew up on [__] country music
in a small town Jason Aldean I'm
actually from a [__] small town but
let's listen to what Trey Crowder he
he's doing a new set and he released a
little bit of his new jokes he's even
he's even got a notepad on the stool
because there's these jokes are so
[__] new that he's working these out
but I I think they're great and this is
almost a three-minute clip that
Tennessee holler posted on Twitter
because they have a blue check so they
can post a longer than a two minute
video but here's a little bit of that
set
I was interested in this story but one
of the first lyrics of this song is like
Hey try a carjacking an old lady in a
red light right and I was like a red
light
what is This Time Square
Legend has it they tried to install some
red lights on the square of my hometown
in the 80s but that didn't take
because I kid you not people kept
shooting them out
in the middle of the night I was like
that's not the number one he's singing
about right he's from uh Eastern Macon
Georgia have you heard of Macon Georgia
yeah that means it's not a small town
you've heard of it
[Laughter]
[__] my big parents thing
when I first saw the song you try that
and small
turn I thought
I was gonna find a good pizza a piece of
pizza try that
be a gay teenagers right
that's what I thought it was going to be
you know so I was kind of surprised that
promised me because like the whole song
is about they're all they're getting
fired up about things that are never
gonna happen like they're they're
worried about like like unlike big city
antifa coming there to [__] [__] up and
it's like they they ain't coming here
I'm trying to go to Somalia man
I got better coffee there
like imagine antifa having a meeting and
they're like yeah well no all the
media's eyes are on Portland and la and
the big cities and everything but where
we can really make the most impact with
our message is bucks North Tennessee
but
it's just ridiculous it pisses me out
too because there's plenty of things
that are being done in small towns that
they couldn't be mad about they could be
saying about you know what I mean like
singing about them [__] shipping all
the jobs the way you're shutting the
hospital down making you a staging
ground for heroin and pill formation
[Applause]
people and politicians
[Music]
and there you go there you have it
um Trey Crowder there uh giving us
comedy giving us comedic relief of what
we need to actually process what is
happening with this broke country eat
boy culture that Jason Aldean has so
stoked here and intentionally like Texas
Paul said and like Gabe said it's
intentional but we need this comedic
relief and we need this type of art to
push back but the thing that I think
Trey Crowder says the best other than
some of the jokes about some of the
lyrics in the in the music is about hey
man you could actually be actually
making art and singing about [__] that
really does affect small towns that's
really [__] them up but they won't do
it because this is why this is not
country music Texas Paul it's because
they're not really speaking truth to
power they are the power they are the
power and they're telling you what you
should and shouldn't believe it's
authoritarianism by telling you you
should be on the side of the cops is am
I right or am I right
oh man this is not country music and I
will not let them have it it's not going
to be that way I grew up on country
music folks and I I grew up with Hank
Williams Jr before he was an [__]
I mean you know A Country Boy Can
Survive was a good song be proud of who
you are but being proud of who you are
doesn't have to be Jason Aldean [__]
[__] talking about you know [__]
fake [__] about other people which
brings me to my second Point there's
some troll in the comment talking about
Portland rest in peace Portland [__]
the the the the what happened in
Portland was in like a two-block area
you know that's it Portland is fine you
know back when they were trying to they
were trying to say Paris was being
burned I took my audience to a live cam
feed of Paris I said does this city look
like it's on fire it is not they always
say this [__] you know so person that
was trolling in the comments let me
educate you what happened in Portland
was in a little two block area your
fiction that you have in your head
that's making you love this [__]
song that is not country music it is not
what country people are like Tony says
100 this is not country
whatever I don't know I you know I don't
know if they were trolls
it sounds like uh it sounds like they
are a uh a sparkler they were being
sarcastic okay cool yeah yeah because I
guess that's something I said something
that Hal jokes about that's why well it
is we welcome all joking and sarcasm and
and uh and Texas Paul always jumps on on
trolls so yeah but my point was and
that's why I said I didn't know if
they're a troll or not I'm talking about
that point they say that [__] all the
time yeah right talk about it right even
even though it's sarcasm in the track
how makes that joke even even though
it's sarcasm in the chat that's they're
they're saying it repeating the stupid
[__] line as if it's some sort of
argument that the right would make
speaking
to that to that point it's a you know
it's one of those things where the
Republican party will show you clips and
they won't show you the full context
like I had friends in Portland who
sarcasm I have friends in Portland who
live during in 2020 right and they live
there during that time and you know the
Republicans would like you to believe
that everything was on fire and the
courthouse is burning down and police
stations were blowing up and all this
stuff and I had friends who were walking
downtown during the day and they're like
yeah there's like some graffiti on the
wall here but that's it there's like
nothing going on and I and I think it's
you you see this all the time with the
with Republicans where they try to show
you the worst
case scenario the worst of what's
happening and what do you end up finding
out it's the complete opposite or the
people who are causing destruction are
the Boogaloo boys or white supremacists
or anyone else who's trying to instigate
to cause exactly the point to cause a a
harmful image of a group of people right
those black people made all this happen
and it's like no no no no no
you guys historically
you do it all the time it's a it's a
vicious cycle that you guys do which is
white supremacists come in they [__]
prod and poke and instigate an issue and
then they back away once everything's on
fire and go oh look who's around
it's not us what does it happen to walk
by and notice this
well uh I I I'm gonna bring up Captain
terp here it says spark Chasm as all the
sparkers are welcome and so is your your
sarcasm we'll try to we'll try to keep
uh Texas Texas is Paul and be here
they made you know I wasn't attacking
that person I know you know I love the
sparklers I love Hal Sparks but the
point is still the same it's the exact
point that Gabe just made right that is
not country music country music is not
taking a bunch of pretend [__] that
really doesn't apply or happen like Trey
Crowder said this is not really small
town this isn't right nobody's
carjacking in a small town not because
you're a badass not because you're a
tough guy because the cars are [__] in
small towns because they're full of
poverty you know the average car in a
small town is not something sweet no you
want a you know a hundred thousand
dollar jacked up pickup truck go to a
city go to a city in a small town you're
going to get a 12 year old beat up piece
of crap that nobody's gonna carjack
right you know that's why it ain't
happening but also I mean not only that
you're in a small town everyone knows
everyone they see your face they know
that it's you know Johnny Walker down
the street at you know whatever they
know exactly who the person is they know
their parents they know their family
word's going to get around like this
isn't something and not only that but
you know to trace point and your point
you wouldn't go to a small town to go
carjack someone like why would you do
that in a small town where again
everyone knows you and if it's a small
town everyone's got their right to maybe
bear arms they've got their right to
track you down I mean Tony was talking
about last week living on a farm and
being like half a mile to a mile away
from other people and they you know they
were comfortable keeping their their
keys in the car but it's one of those
things like No One's Gonna drive out of
their way to go to some small farm or a
small town or whatever to go steal
something only for you to be the only
thing in sight for a mile to go right
it's not like you can hide behind a
building or or go into a highway or
something like that you're going to be
seen I mean you're you're basically just
you're you're just like a a you know
black dot and a speck of white in the
sense of like you're able to be noticed
very easily and that there's nothing
around you right and yeah they're gonna
chase you they're going to find you you
can't get away from it I'm gonna show
you bucks North Tennessee before we move
on to uh trash Greg Abbott here I want
to show you a clip of him talking about
how he like he's gonna he's gonna take
his right to murder women and children
in the river all the way to Supreme
Court but before that I want to show you
um the Bucks North Tennessee it is a
real [__] place Trey cat was not
making that up it sounds made up it is
not there is a bucks North Tennessee
um believe it or not is it is a spring
in Hickman County I'm not making this up
this is real it's in Hickman County uh
located on Sugar Creek oh my God just
down uh stream from South Fork on Sugar
Creek now the weather is uh you know
pretty nice there today it's 89 degrees
uh the humidity's a [__] though and the
local time uh it's 1208 so so it's
Central Time there in Bucks North
Tennessee and there's not a single
famous person uh from Buck snort as well
so this is this is what you get when you
um when you have truth to power comedy
right here because you know I'm sure uh
not to not to say that bucks Norton has
these problems but small towns all
around the country have the problems of
poverty jobs leaving those Towns at
hospitals Schools public libraries
because Republicans absolutely control a
lot of those areas and absolutely will
not allow will not allow those kind of
modern conveniences in these small towns
and the reason why is so they can blame
it on Democrats see what they're doing
they're taking away your hospitals
they're taking away your public schools
and we need to have charter schools and
no hospitals and you to have no jobs
that way I wonder who put those things
in those towns in the first place yeah
who who created those jobs who offered
that employment those opportunities and
then think about who took those things
away right
well it is Republicans I don't know if
they know that or not but um
they don't I mean could you imagine a
carjacking in a small town I mean that
would be freaking hilarious man hey lady
get out of the car
boy
don't make me take my shoe off get get I
mean and that would be the whole damn
carjacking right there I mean it would
be I mean Jesus Christ the the freaking
fiction that this this whole mentality
and it's all just to say oh you live in
a small town you're tough you're special
you know you're not no you're not
well I had the clip for Greg Abbott uh
on the ready here but I've lost it now
hang on a second let me see if I can
find this son of a [__] Bank
um in the meantime I do want to go to I
do want to go to this guy
yeah car jacket 99 Taurus with 250 000
miles right right right right right
that's exactly right here here it is on
Fox News this is Greg Abbott he's saying
this out loud folks this isn't like some
sort of [__] tape that I got of him
saying this in a in a closed room
somewhere on a recording this
[__] is on Fox News saying this
[__] listen there are 29 Port Century in
the state of Texas people if they are
sticking Asylum can go to those ports of
Entry to try to enter the United States
it is completely illegal for anybody to
try to cross the border between the
ports of Entry all the Bible
Administration has to do is to enforce
the laws already on the books to prevent
people from Crossing between the ports
of Entry until the bond Administration
does that Texas will be stepping up to
do so so let me ask you Texas Paul
because you live and you've seen the
Border uh when is Greg Abbott going to
say that he's just going to hire snipers
to shoot him coming across the border
because that's what it sounds like he
wants to do
yeah that's what it sounds like he wants
to do it really and you know what's
worse about it he doesn't even give a
[__] about us Texans he doesn't I mean
he's got Texas ranchers and there's a
guy that owns a pecan uh Grove down
there that can't get to the damn River
to pump water because of all the damn
razor wire he told DPS when they were
trying to put it up you can't do that
get off my land you can't do that
they're obstructing Texas ranchers from
getting their cows to the freaking River
I mean this really happens man he
doesn't give us wait wait wait wait a
second wait say I thought Republicans
love farmers and Ranchers
that doesn't it sounds it sounds like
they like political stunts where they
kill brown people more than they like
farmers and ranchers that's what it
sounds like to me hmm uh here he is
again uh on the same Fox News where
Brett Barron is asking about this let's
listen it is in the public interest for
the State of Texas to be uh safeguarding
and securing our border from people
entering the United States illegally for
another we believe that statute does not
apply in any way because uh what state
of Texas is doing uh through those buoys
is not in violation of that statute so
where are they going to go to court here
when they file Sue what what happens are
you going to have a judge down in Texas
on the federal level
yeah so so Brad a lawsuit was filed a
few hours ago uh in the federal court in
the state of Texas we will litigate
initially in a federal district court in
the state of Texas uh if we lose there
we will be going to the fifth Circuit
Court of Appeals and eventually all the
way to the United States Supreme Court
because Texas is defending its
sovereignty and its constitutional right
to secure the border of our state and
our country it's a federal border it is
not a state border I hate to give gray
gamut the news there but here's here's
what's happening so so the federal
government is suing Greg Abbott not
because he's killing women and children
there's not a statute on the books for
that I think that's what we need to move
to really in this country where we our
federal government can hold Governors
accountable who are committing human
rights violations that's what I think we
should do we should move to that well I
mean if you're if you're also putting in
place the the means of killing someone
right by putting the buoys by putting
the razor wire by making difficult to
get out from from uh
from the Bowie area
um I feel like there's a Justified cause
for the Department of Justice to come
after you and you know a good point
um that that Margie maid is notice how
he didn't mention the razor wire right
right notice how he's saying oh we are
we are well within our right to protect
the sovereignty of Texas
but he won't go into specifics of what
the means and what the actions that he's
going about well yeah because it's
getting to have to describe how he's
[__] murdering people in the river
listen folks what the federal government
the only law that they're allowed to use
here is that Texas did not seek proper
permission from the Army Corps of
Engineers to put this in a water a
federal waterway that is how they're
suing them they're not suing them based
on he's [__] murdering women and
children because there's not a statute
that exists for the federal government
to sue a governor who is committing
human rights violations just like all
the rest of these [__] Governors Ron
DeSantis these [__] in
Tennessee and Missouri who are [__]
passing legislation to try to get rid of
a certain group of people in our country
who are trying to who are trying to rid
ourselves of of the lgbtq community by
legislating them out of existence this
is human rights violations when you take
away women's right to health care that's
a human right
violation and our federal government and
the only way we're going to do this is
to engage in our democracy the only way
we're going to change this is to lean
way the [__] in to being intolerant of
intolerance and be [__] pissed about
this kind of [__] because this is
ridiculous and the federal government we
need to move to a federal government
statute where our government us we the
[__] people can hold the governor
accountable when he's committing human
rights violations because that's exactly
what this is this ain't got a goddamn
thing to do with that Waterway it ain't
got a goddamn thing to do with the Army
Corps of Engineers it has to do with
human [__] life that's what it has to
do with it and I'm I'm actually I'm I'm
actually uh to believe that the federal
government is is poised to lose this to
lose this lawsuit if you want to know
the honest truth because I think the
only reason why they're bringing this
lawsuit is the only statute that they
can do and to stand in court and say
that this is about a Waterway and
obstructing a Waterway is [__]
ridiculous it's about human [__] life
and Let Me Tell You Folks you're going
to be real disappointed because the
federal government isn't going to be
able to make that argument that it's
about human rights violations and human
life in that River that's not the
argument that they're going to be able
to make because they have no
jurisdiction the Army Corps of Engineers
has no jurisdiction over people's lives
in this country they don't they don't
have it and neither does that [__]
statute it needs to change and you're
the ones who can change it
let me throw let me throw something out
there Tony
yeah Mexico the government of Mexico has
jurisdiction and the federal government
has jurisdiction in this in this
instance
the Department of Public Safety officers
our state troopers were ordered not to
give water to immigrants
it's 100 degree days out there they've
had people passing out with heat stroke
they had a woman caught up in this razor
wire with 19 year old mother who was
pregnant uh could not free herself
ended up having a miscarriage right
there stuck in razor wire
at the river and was found hours later
let me just throw this out there a
person acts with a depraved indifference
to human life when having unconscious
having a conscious objective not to kill
but to harm
like say withholding water or leaving
somebody tied up in razor wire putting
razor wire out and then not having
people around to go check and see if
anybody's being hurt or killed he or she
engages in torture or a brutal prolonged
and potentially fatal course of conduct
against a particularly vulnerable
vulnerable victim that my friend is the
legal definition of assault in the first
degree
that is exactly what they need to be
charged with they need to start a
resting DPS Troopers they need to start
arresting DPS management they need to
start they need to file charges against
Greg Abbott for assault I first say this
I hate to tell you this but they're not
going to
I I love I love I love I love the idea
of it but they're not going to and the
reason why is because the federal judge
the federal government has nerd no
jurisdiction to to to charge Greg Abbott
with human rights violations they just
don't have it because he has the
authoritarian uh wing of his party
supporting his [__] as the governor
of Texas and all the while all the while
in Texas that this is happening folks
where where Greg Abbott is drowning
women and children in the [__] River
he's drowning them in the [__] River
and he's cheering it and the Jason
Aldean fans are cheering it oh we love
Jason Aldean and loved drowning brown
people in a [__] River
they're [__] scumbags they're the
worst of us but all the while all the
while [__] lieutenant governor
Patrick who's gonna be the presiding
officer over the impeachment trial of
Ken Paxton the disgraced attorney
general supposedly the [__] leading
law enforcement officer in the state of
Texas he's been suspended he's gonna go
on and trial for impeachment
governor Patrick apparently received
three million dollars
from a Ken Paxton pack to make sure I
don't know what to make sure of [__]
Patrick isn't in a race till 2026. at
the end of 2026. I couldn't even I
couldn't even dream of what this three
million dollars is supposed to pay for
Texas Paul seems a little sus to me
and otherwise Republicans on the [__]
Hill in the house are worried about some
[__] payment made to Hunter Biden for
five million dollars you scumbag
[__]
you re do you you understand why I come
here every [__] day and I'm pissed
why [__] yell and scream and I say
the f word and I don't give a [__]
because of [__] like that
Greg Abbott's drowning [__]
drowning families in the river
and Ken Paxton has given the lieutenant
governor
Dan Patrick three million dollars to
make sure he doesn't get impeached
and we're worried about on the hill
today Hunter Biden's dick pics and some
money that was given to the Biden family
that never made its way to Joe Biden
they have no evidence of that because it
doesn't exist you [__] you
[__] and that's why I want to
do what I'm doing on patreon because I
know I tell the audience to engage in
the democracy and two hours a day I have
to tell you about these [__] scumbags
and what they're doing so that you can
engage in your democracy I don't have
enough time on this show to give you the
tools and that's why I want to do this
thing on patreon to give people the
tools and you know what we should start
today right here on the show I was gonna
do phone and bonehead for Tommy
tuberville but I think today today it's
Texas Republicans folks I think what you
should do is you should go online
there's a website called five calls it's
five calls they got scripts on there
they tell you exactly what to do they
tell you exactly what to do and what to
say when you call and you should call
right now you should look up the phone
numbers look up the phone numbers of
Greg Abbott look up the phone numbers of
Dan Patrick and Ken Paxton call call and
tell them how [__] discouraged you
are of how much corruption
and human rights violations that they're
committing be nice don't do threats
that's not what you do that's not how it
works you gotta be nice on the phone
but you tell them you give them your
dissent that you disagree with their
policies and you definitely disagree
with the corruption of of Dan Patrick
receiving three million dollars from Ken
Paxton
and and question why he did that
question them question why did he do
that I want to know
as a citizen of this country a citizen
this state of Texas I know we have
plenty of people that watch from Texas
that could call but these are their
state reps so phone and bonehead today
phone uh bonehead that's what we're
gonna call it I I wasn't sure about the
name but God damn it makes sense now
doesn't it Texas Paul
absolutely
that that's a great idea Tony you know
what you know what you know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna commit to this uh
after the show today I'm gonna go on
patreon anyone on the patreon okay come
on I'm gonna record I'll go through the
five calls website with you I'll show
you where to go how to find this uh well
I'll show you how to find these [__]
phone numbers I'll give you the phone
number so you can phone a bonehead and
then after that I will post it publicly
so that you can so we can figure out
together how to do this correctly
because there is a correct way to call
your representatives there's a correct
way to call these [__] and
there's an incorrect way and you do not
want to do it incorrectly
yeah I mean just like last night there
was Eric swalwell he got threatening
calls about a guy coming in to you know
can you pull up that story I want to
show how not to do it let's let's show
how not to do it that that seems way
more important than what you're what you
are going to say is what not to say
because you you do not want to threaten
these people you do you do not want to
break the law when you're calling to me
you definitely don't want to try to
threaten someone I mean it was very much
within the Maga wheelhouse you make a
threat about taking you know deadly
action against someone and then when you
are then caught by authorities you go
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa guys guys I I
wasn't I was just kidding I didn't
really mean it and then they tried to
play I would try drug use or alcohol or
mental health no no no no you made those
comments you made the thread now [__]
around and find out because there is no
way in which you can do that in our
society and not have something happen to
you and the fact that many of these
people think that there are no
repercussions that there is no way for
them uh where they they think oh I can
get away with saying this I can totally
get away with showing up with my AR-15
or my knife or my gun or whatever it
might be thinking that they can do this
without any sort of consequence of Law
and Order
is it ridiculous because you know why
it's because they come from this this
Mega mentality where Trump says hey you
know go beat up that that [__] or or
that son of a [__] or this or that like
you're at the rally go fight that
[__] whatever it might be
that's the that's the belief they have
that white supremacist uh
domestic terrorists violence first
approach if you don't agree with me or
my ideologies don't line up with you
then you are now going to be at the the
end of my gun right or the end of my
weapon or whatever it is
um it's just I mean that's that is the
Republican party and there's no no
getting away from that that is the
Republican party that they have built
because they followed a
a circus leader that is Trump
and all of his his lead on on what they
what they thought was appropriate and
what was acceptable in society uh Amanda
says no swearing family yeah you don't
want to you don't want to go all Tony
Michaels on yeah don't do that don't do
it don't do that don't do that you you
want to be much calmer than I am uh my
my rhetoric won't get you anywhere on
the phone with him you have to be very
measured you have to know what you're
going to say the best thing to do is get
a script and I again here's what I'm
gonna do because someone also posted uh
let's see where's it at someone posted
uh no threats just votes yes yes uh you
can't you can't do threats um well the
only
I will say you can threaten that yeah
for them that I will primary you I will
vote I will support the person who was
running against you in the primary I
will make sure that you're not in office
by supporting the person who is running
against you I mean that's the when I say
threat that's what I mean I mean
threatening to use your vote against
them primary them and saying look you
have no chance I will not support you if
you don't do this thing using your vote
as your weapon right we have to use the
ballot we have to use the ballot in this
case that is as what we need um someone
said um please post how to do this so
what I'll do is I'll do it on patreon
because I promise the patreon people
that we would do this on patreon so I
will I will do it on patreon then I will
post it publicly somewhere for you guys
to find uh so that you guys
um digital waterfall says I'm not on
patreon so I I'm sorry I'm lost okay so
here's what we're doing on on patreon
I'm doing a new project we're calling it
the uh the round table of democracy
where we're all getting together on
patreon and we're coming up with ways to
have workshops to engage in your
democracy and to get engaged in the
Democracy because I always say on the
show engage engage engage and I thought
well maybe I'm missing a component maybe
I'm not giving you the tools to engage I
can't I can't show you why you should
engage and the tools all on the show
it's just not a [__] time there's not
enough time to give you the news why why
you should and where you should Point
your engagement and and why that's so
important so I got to do it outside the
show so the proper place to do it was
patreon but I'm not going to hide it
from you we're going to do it on patreon
together with the with the patreon
members and then I'm gonna post it
publicly so you can see it if you want
to get in the live chat or participate
sometimes live on camera you can go over
to patreon to check it out
um and see what we're gonna do over
there but we're going to provide this
information for you for the public to to
see I'm not going to hide it from you
I'm not going to get it we're just going
to develop it on patreon and then show
it to you guys and it'll be things like
phone a bonehead like I'll do today
again I'm gonna go all I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna go to the the five calls
website and show you what they have to
offer on there and to show you where to
go to find the phone numbers how to find
the phone numbers I'll do that real
quick and it'll be a quick little
workshop I had a phone a bonehead and a
bonehead today is Greg Abbott and Texas
Republicans and that's important and
especially if you're in Texas it's
important to call and even if you're not
in Texas you can still call and say hey
I'm very discouraged by the news I
cannot believe
of what the policies are down there and
we can do it with a script there's a
script that you just say the script and
uh so we'll so we'll do that a lot of
people are showing the uh the find calls
uh uh website here it's fivecalls.org
it's fivecalls.org so we'll go to that
website
um when the show ends I'll I'll take a
little break and then we'll go to
patreon and we'll do that and then uh
hopefully I'll have that posted by today
or tomorrow that you can see it publicly
that way if you want to do it outside
the patreon you you get a chance to see
that and know exactly what to do when to
call and where to call and how to call
um so it's very very important
um and Steve points had a good point yes
patreon costs money it supports me it
supports Tony yes uh it does cost a
little bit five dollars is the is the
least amount if you want to go join
patreon I'm not saying you have to uh to
get access to to these to this content
I'm gonna provide it publicly after
we're done doing it but if you want to
participate in it live and and
participate uh live and developing it
then you want to go to the patreon.com
Johnny Michaels and and we'll do it
there
um but we'll do phone and bonehead after
this speaking of patreon uh we might as
well ask Gabe here you have it you have
a what was that did you want to play
that today or yeah let's give it a go
yeah we got a little bit of time let's
how long is how long is this one it's uh
um uh hold on I can tell you right now
it is uh give me that link give me that
link oh yeah I I forgot we were going to
show this uh Eric swallow thing too
here's what not to do so give me that
link while I'm doing that I'll show you
this uh Eric swallow thing
um
Joshua a hall here says I was putting in
prison over a phone call it was to Eric
it was more than just a phone call I
don't remember making the call or it's
contents of it this is what Joe Biden
and American's doj is doing to us he's
whining about uh sending a he sent a
threat and called and sent a threat
um Eric schwal says can someone please
explain how this guy who is currently in
prison is able to tweet he called my
office and said he's got assault rifles
and it's coming to kill me hmm
you don't that's why you what you'd want
to do folks
do none of that you want you want to use
the power of your ballot the power of
your vote and the power of your voice
but that is that is the the culmination
that is the core of what the Republican
party is now right right
Republican party is maga maga is
Republican party there is no
conservative anymore there is none of
that it is
believes that you can threaten people's
lives and not only uh not only elected
officials but their staff and say
because you don't agree with me or
because you support fauci Biden any of
the mayor Garland any of these people
then your life is now in my crosshairs
and that's totally fine and now this
guy's like oh well I was under the
influence I don't remember doing it was
mental health there was drugs or was
drinking it was this or was that I I it
wasn't me I swear no no no no look man
you [__] around you found out well
here's that caught here's the here's the
community notes read this Hall pled
guilty to threatening to kill Congress
he pled guilty yeah [__] pled
guilty he didn't he didn't get go to
trial he pled guilty to threatening to
kill congressman swalware and his
staffers on multiple occasions on phone
calls to the congressman's office Joshua
Hill was also found guilty of fraud oh
my God for impersonating a member of the
Trump family to raise money for a fake
organization hmm Joshua Holmes
everyone's a grifter I mean that's what
it is boy he went to prison over a phone
call couldn't have happened to a better
dude let me know it was just it was a
perfectly good phone call right right it
was okay it was two perfectly good it
was three
it seems like he got that somewhere
maybe he is a member of the Trump family
hell who knows Texas Paul we're going to
watch um Gabe Sanchez's new uh what was
that uh here here just just real quick I
how long was it Gabe you said like 10
minutes 10 minutes okay well here we go
we're gonna watch uh
Gabe Sanchez
what was that and this is about Marjorie
Taylor green then we'll we'll talk about
it on the other side Gabe Sanchez what
was that welcome to what was that I'm
Gabe Sanchez just when you thought
Marjorie Taylor green couldn't humiliate
herself anymore she hits a new low by
not doing her job and instead appearing
in a cringy mega rap music video
MTG magazine VP MTG magazine VP but
before we get into this make sure to
like this video subscribe to this
channel if you haven't already and ring
that notification Bell so you never miss
another video now we all know that
politics can be a bit theatrical at
times but wow uh where do I even start
with this one well I guess the first
thing I should say is welcome to what
was that's behind the Maga music
featuring fellatio blow wait what do you
mean I've been saying his name wrong
you're telling me his name is not
fellatio blow it's Forgiato blow all
kidding aside magarap is a real genre of
music and I use the term music very
liberally here it consists of right wing
topics like patriotism bigotry and of
course Donald Trump because they're
definitely not a cult leave it to Maga
to somehow ruin rap music more than Iggy
Azalea could ever dream of
just images
somehow Mega rap is an actual thing and
its found in father is this lyrical
imbecile Kurt Jance AKA mayor of
magaville AKA fellatio blow sorry
Forgiato blow look I honestly don't know
if the blowing chances rap name is
because this music blows or if it's
because he likes to drive around with a
trump blow up doll actually upon closer
look it appears to be a trump sex style
which doesn't make this situation any
better again these are the people who
love to scream that they are not in a
cult speaking of magical cult members
Margaret Taylor green worked with chance
in his new music video which he actually
dedicated to her and
wow does it Blow when I think of
Margaret Taylor green I think of many
things racist deranged conspiracy
theorists hypocritical Christian who
cheated on her former husband multiple
times but rap music is definitely not
one of them the last time Marge tried to
enter the rap game was when Dr Dre
served her with the cease and assist
back in January after she made a little
promotional video of herself using his
song Still Dre it's stated you are
wrongfully exploiting this work through
the various social media Outlets to
promote your divisive and hateful
political agenda Dr Dre has not and will
never Grant you permission to broadcast
or disseminate any of his music anyway
thankfully green doesn't actually rap in
the video with chance she decided to
save the world from that auditory
torture instead she took on the role of
a music video extra sitting on a Golden
Throne as if she's the queen of cringe
and who knows maybe this video is a
subtle message to her constituents to
say don't worry about your health care
or the economy because I'm here sitting
magnificent on my gilded chair so
without further Ado here's the music
video the Democrats are a party of
pedophiles they support grooming
children even Joe Biden the president
himself supports children being
sexualized and having transgender
surgeries sexualizing children is what
pedophiles do to children
wait I'm sorry I can't let you listen to
this crime against humanity you know
what instead I'll just read you some of
jance's poetic lyrics as if I was
actually him she's fighting for our
children she's fighting for our freedom
she's fighting for the dance this is
fighting good okay just stop the music
no no we're done I'm sorry I just can't
read these lyrics with a straight face
or I'm in a jancy's face and now I look
like a huge idiot permanent marker comes
off right anyway I don't know about you
but I'm a bit curious to know how much
time and effort it takes to write such
an elegant Masterpiece you uh sent me
the rough version of that track and I
was amazed I was like well how long
would it take you to write this and your
answer surprisingly 10 minutes 10
minutes to write
was put together in 10 minutes I've seen
middle school projects executed better
than this I mean this thing was so low
budget they had Marge's boyfriend
right-wing commentator Brian Glenn
working the smoke machine Jance is
wearing the same MTG Magus MVP hoodie as
before Marge is sitting on a car smiling
and then saying Maga which honestly
makes sense when you remember that she
struggles with any words that are more
than two syllables and then they've got
some random non-bodyguard looking guy
who was probably recruited from the same
casting website as Candace Owens and
Lauren bobert this is the type of low
quality content that Maga loves to blast
from their Trump themed trucks just like
the one that Jance owns I mean I hate to
sound like a broken record but manga is
a cult they have no personality they
look the same they sound the same and
many of them are just gripping off the
backs of any gullible person that they
can find within their party and the
funniest and most predictable thing
about this whole music video
collaboration is Marjory Taylor Green's
hypocrisy in a recent statement to
Newsweek green said most rap videos
exploit women glorify drugs and violence
but Forgiato blows new video is about
calling out the less grooming agenda
data in protecting our children from
genital mutilation okay let's just clear
up this disinformation children do not
receive gender affirming surgery nor is
anyone literally chopping off the
private parts of young kids also for a
group that claims Democrats are
indoctrinating America with gay
propaganda Republicans sure love to
shove other people's dicks in our faces
without consent three seconds over as
long as Ms Casa Cortez can get equal
time I will let the screen wrap up just
a thought but someone might want to
search Marjorie Taylor Green's computer
for all that revenge porn on Hunter
Biden that she has anyway when she talks
about the issues with other rap what
she's really saying is she doesn't like
black rap artists or their music because
surprise surprise she's a racist but
back to Marge's hypocrisy I can't help
but laugh because she's promoting and
working with Jance who has rapped about
sex trafficking in women for money
[Music]
as well as many music video about
shooting his girlfriend duct taping her
body in trash bags and then dumping her
in a lake and who can forget about his
collaboration with the infamous
contestant from Dancing With the
seditionist Roger Stone you know
or that time you performed with the
proud boys you know the neo-fascist
white nationalist organization that has
many of its members charged with crimes
from January 6. and according to Marge's
boyfriend they're not only friends with
chance but they're also fans of his
music uh Forgiato blow who is a friend
of both of ours and we've uh actually
had an opportunity uh to to have uh
lunch with him and one day and get to
meet him he's got some great music I
really don't understand maga's taste in
music like he thinks this song about
boycotting Bud Light is great
[Music]
oh
move over Shakespeare there's a new poet
in magaville and as you would expect his
song about boycotting Target was even
worse
[Music]
than preaching the game
LGBT you don't win too far in case any
of you were actually curious about why
he made those songs here's his [__]
explanation I think it's just showing
what the world needs like I said you
know it all starts with the children
somebody has to stand up for the kids
someone stand up for the children that's
why they start with you know this agenda
with the with the younger group
um they're easily uh manipulized by wait
did he just say manipulize um they're
easily uh manipulized by making them
feel like you know this is what
everybody's doing that's what you should
be doing and it's it's not right it's
not right at all yeah we are clearly
clearly we're here but then again Trump
did say I love the poorly educated
speaking of poorly educated one of the
other Mega rap artists in that Target
video is Jimmy Levy a former contestant
on American Idol from 2020 except he
looks a bit different my name is Jimmy
Levy awesome and tell me about your life
um I grew up in a psychic family okay
and my mom was in Ripley's Believe It or
Not when she was 13 and I see go I don't
want to follow in the psychic footsteps
even though I have the gift and it's
probably gonna be there forever I want
to do full-time music why am I not
surprised the guy who claims to see
ghosts is not only a trump supporter but
also a q Anon believer in a flat earther
I got on on American Idol and I went far
went to the end of Hollywood week
and you know I started hanging out more
and and getting more experiences with
how sick these people were in Hollywood
these people are drinking the blood of
children these people are injecting a
chemical called adrenochrome that they
extract from children that are scared
this is really happening and this is the
most popular chemical used in Hollywood
for the Youth it's a fountain of youth
they say it's disgusting and it needs to
be exposed many Jim cavazil cavizel
tried to expose it and was called crazy
but it's the truth
this is what is being used
these people worship the devil oh and
Levy also says that he's Jewish which
makes his Q on anti-Semitism a bit
confusing but also totally on brand for
a trump supporter none of these Mega
idiots are who they say they are it's
all a facade they're just liars and
grifters looking for their next con for
example Jance is not self-made at all he
reportedly inherited five million
dollars from his parents and is also the
grandson of successful AutoTrader
magazine founder Stuart Arnold is it
just me or does Jance feel like a
character out of Malibu's Most Wanted
kick a freestyle
okay
even with all this family money and
connections Jans had to buy a record
deal and he still found a little success
in the music industry that's how much he
sucks chances no different than Margaret
Taylor green who is not an actual
business owner or Donald Trump who was
not an actual billionaire or any of the
other Republicans who lie about their
experience accomplishments and claim to
actually care about their constituents
and instead of focusing on meaningful
legislation or engaging with
constituents Marjory Taylor green is
working on low quality rap videos that
wouldn't even get aired on local
broadcast so while we can laugh and roll
our eyes at a rap video let's all
remember that the real joke is kinda on
us the voters who put people like her in
office it's a sobering reminder that we
need to stay engaged informed and above
all demand better from our elected
officials because if not we're just
gonna get more people like Marjorie
Taylor green showing dick picks during
committee hearings well that's all for
me today thanks so much for watching
this episode of what was that if you
want to see more episodes like this make
sure to like this video subscribe to the
channel and turn on notifications and if
you want to be a part of what makes my
show possible plus get access to
episodes before they go public plus a
bonus show on the weekend and even more
you can do so by going to patreon.com I
am Gabe Sanchez
and there you have it there's what was
that oh man
oh man man these kids man they're
getting monopolized monopolized
manipulated they're getting monopolized
monopolized did he mean nippleized I
don't know what it is I mean it's always
it's always something sexual in their
mind and they're just projecting out
there it's a Freudian slip he's like
manipulated nippleized monopolized a
fellatio slip and then
uh how did uh holy crap how does Gabe go
through this much or how does it go into
this forever uh it takes a while I'm
just I'm I'm an internet sleuth I go
through and I find all that [__] and
then I bring it you know I mean bring it
forward to laugh at he's the same guy
that comes up with all the faces in the
uh in the thumbnails this is the I I
when I do thumbnails I come up with some
pretty good ones but Gabe Sanchez always
finds the best faces
um in the thumbnails so I just know what
to search for you know right well he's
pretty good at finding this stuff that's
why I have him here and I'm like hey man
I need a I need a clip he's a hell a lot
better at finding it than me speaking of
people who can't find [__] um Matt Walsh
can't find his masculinity holy [__]
this guy this guy Texas Paul I tell you
what
um and it's been a while since I talked
about Matt Matt Walsh here on on the
show but
I got to do it it's the Barbie movie
thing the daily wire is all balls deep
into Barbie here or not because they
can't do that they're just not capable
of that sort of thing you know what's
funny about this whole like
um Republic I mean you can show the
Tweet but I I think it's I think it's
funny how much Republicans or Maga or
conservatives or whatever they want to
call themselves they're like oh this
Barbie movie and the gay propagand and
this and that these [__] are
wearing the skinniest of jeans they are
skinny like
their their legs could not breathe
they're so tight they're squeezing in
them in the morning they need help from
their their uh their wife or their
children to slip into those legs because
there was no way there was no way that
they like the fact that they're wearing
skinny jeans there's no way that that
would be acceptable I don't know 10
years ago where now they're they're the
metrosexual look is okay for them well
when do you think daily wire will
release their their uh line of skinny
jeans when do you think they'll release
daily wire skinny treats here's Matt
Walsh in a tweet oh my God this is so
[__] dumb this is so stupid it's
laughable of course it pisses a lot of
people off including I don't know women
because Matt Walsh this is the story
about Barbie really honestly it is is
that these [__] right-wing white
fragile males are so [__] scared of
women they're so terrified of women
here's what he says this is a good time
to remember that feminism has killed
more people than then the atomic bomb it
is perhaps the most destructive force in
human history Jesus Christ trans
ideology its offshoot is competing for
the title this guy is such a [__]
bonehead what the [__] is he talking
about Texas Paul feminism has killed
more people is he talking about abortion
I think that's what he's saying is that
what he's saying is that the empowerment
of women has killed more people than he
does he is terrified that women are
going to come kill him is what it sounds
like to me I wouldn't blame him to be
quite honest but you know it's just me
you know the entire right-wing movement
is that uh you know male Supremacy women
get back into your place the whole
freaking movement when they say we want
to get back to uh you know a time or
when like Jason Aldean said things
they're doing to us you know right it's
primarily women living their lives not
tied to a man having their own
independence making their own decision
decisions and then you get to tell them
you know they don't get to tell them
what to do when to do how to do they
live their own lives they're independent
people they're intelligent that I mean
that's the whole premises of what
premise of what Barbie is I mean she's
an astronaut she's a pilot she's a
doctor she's a you know what I mean she
does her own thing and Ken is just some
eye candy that you know she loves skin
he can come along for the ride but he's
not necessary to her existence you know
I mean come on people did they really
think they were going to be able to take
down Barbie because that's what they
were trying to do yeah
did they realize they really that's
hilarious because it was oh that's
hilarious I play with Barbie dolls for
Christ's sake man I mean me and my
granddaughter have a great time with our
Barbie dolls you know I mean I am the
only person in this house who has
actually put out a call on social media
please somebody tell me how I can
untangle this Barbie hair because it is
fake hair and none of the products work
you know I mean
you know you just gotta cut it you got
to cut the hair and make a weird Barbie
man but that's the the
but but the attack against this movie by
you had Charlie Kirk attacking the trans
actress who played a doctor oh God Ben
Shapiro also attacked the transect
they're very fixated on that then you
had Ted Cruz being like it's a nine Dash
or the nine dash line and uh this is
clearly a pro communist movie you're
gonna tell me that Barbie which is
quite honestly the the symbol of
consumerism and materialism outside of
you know uh
pro-feminist women's rights and saying
you could be anything you want to be but
at its core it's a it's a capitalist
product you're gonna tell me that that a
that a capitalist movie production
company
made a movie about a capitalist toy a
consumerism-based toy and then it's some
secret ploy to help promote the CCP get
the [__] out of here right well you know
they even put the pregnant uh Barbie in
the movie a midge and then name Midge
name but the pregnant Barbie in the
movie so I know what they're so mad
about I know what they're so mad about
but he's still mad I had to tell him
this morning Matt Walsh I said girl
you're such a whiny [__] and I I don't
want any little [__] whiny little [__]
yeah well he is a little [__] but uh
but but I I've taken to uh misgendering
uh Matt Walsh here I I don't know I I
think this is the proper thing to do
everyone says oh you shouldn't Miss
gender people should we not misgender
Matt Walsh should we not I I think we
should he says and here's why he says
feminism Jesus Christ has been
aggressively anti-family since its
Inception Jesus Christ there are there
are only a few short decades between the
first way wave and the legislation of
abortion Nationwide there are no there
is no good feminism it's always been
destructive and poisonous he has scared
Texas Paul he is scared that women won't
want to marry men that is literally what
he's saying that oh my God women don't
want well listen when you got a bunch of
dudes like you Matt Walsh no one wants
to [__] marry you no one no one wants
to [__] marry you and sell whiny
little [__] no one Jesus Christ
exactly I mean that that's their fear is
that nobody is going to want to marry a
Matt Walsh unless they're destitute and
broke I mean that's that's that's
exactly he's telling you exactly who
they are
but you know back to games communism
point I have built a four foot tall four
foot tall Barbie mansion
let me tell you this is capitalism folks
I have looked at my credit card
statements and said Jesus Christ this
woman is in my pocket I mean
this is capitalism baby let me tell you
her Barbie's RV cost me as much as my RV
man I mean it ain't no wonder
unemployment so goddamn low Texas Paul
can't stop buying Barbie [__] oh my God
that's why we have low in unemployment
oh man you know I do want to bring
something up though that's been going
around social media
um and it's this this uh back and forth
from the left because there's a lot of
pushback uh on the right that's like hey
you guys are a bunch of chuckleheads but
some on the left are like oh if you're
posting about Barbie then you're you're
against the strike [__] that's not
true that's not true if you're not
getting paid to post for a Barbie then
you're not then you're not you're not
against the strike so get over that [__]
really quick okay let's let's stop that
[__] um I want to show you stupid if
if you're bitching about a movie that's
out today you're bitching about
something that was filmed what game a
year and a half ago
yeah they filmed uh actually here
because they were in Santa Monica I can
tell you right now
[Music]
because I remember watching video and I
was like what are they gonna do with
this movie
um they
filmed this out here
uh while he's looking that up there's
one thing I want to add the first black
Barbie came out in 1980 and the same
people like Matt Walsh the same kind of
people were screaming
can't we just have anything that's just
white I mean we have to do this about
everything do we have to have black
people involved in everything we want we
want something oh my god well you know
what I got to have white Barbies I got
footage here pieces of [__] people I got
footage here of Matt walls wait this is
it looks like Matt Walsh it looks like
this guy's inspiring to be Matt Walsh
um here let's see let's see what the uh
what the religious right say about
divorce and and families let's let's see
what they say so if you've been married
for a period of time and you just don't
like your spouse you don't get along
together and you hate each other's guts
or they are unfaithful to you I'm sorry
but you cannot divorce him whoa what
causes would God to join together let
not man put us under
I don't even care if the person is a
reprobate and they hate God and they
hate you and they if even if they're
like an Ax Murderer
you cannot legally divorce them in the
sight of God now here's the thing you
know your spouse turns out to be some
kind of reprobate Ax Murderer then I'm
not gonna stay in the same house you
know I'm gonna flee and go on the other
side of the world
you know what I'm not you know you
shouldn't do is divorce it oh God
because that would be adultery Jesus
Christ you would just essentially
separate from that person because you're
in danger of your life I mean if they're
abusing your children get away from that
person but you know what you wouldn't
have the grounds to actually get a
divorce you would just separate from
that person protect yourself and your
family
even in that extreme situation it hadn't
you still don't have the ability to get
divorced
holy [__] that's Matt Walsh folks well
it's not Mash well it's like it's like
uh Matt Walsh's brother I think
I would I would like to add that this
this what he's preaching from this part
of the Bible if you keep reading they
explain to you that your wife is your
property and that is [__] too right
well his name is Barbie proved that is
[__] right exactly uh this Christian
hate preacher at this account you gotta
follow
and you got to follow this account I
don't know if you're following them or
not Jesus Christ he better this guy
better go have a conversation with
Lauren bobert and Margaret Taylor green
I know because these These are people
that within they are Maga they are this
man right here but they're gonna go
saying this [__] though oh yeah
absolutely his name is dude he's gonna
say you you don't get divorced I mean
like the fact that he even brought up
abuse right against children
he's like oh no no get away from him
don't do anything okay so like how am I
supposed to handle my assets when I file
my [__] taxes I still have to have
contact with this [__] idiot and this
creep and this abuser
run away from the [__] Ax Murderer
you better keep that Union solid legally
The Eyes Of God Well here here's his
name Duncan Urban
I don't know Duncan here piece of [__]
yeah Duncan here someone needs to go
check on his wife to be quite honest
someone needs to do a wellness check on
his wife this seems like total
projection I don't know if there's an Ax
Murderer wherever this guy is from like
there's some I asked murderer still on
the loose but I think we found our guy
hey someone get a hold of the police I
found the ax murderer that's right here
there are two crimes that I have noticed
in this video the things that he said
yeah that's the first crime the second
crime is that goddamn suit get it Taylor
okay get it just get it [__] brought
in brought in at the sides here
I had I had to show that one last video
no Gabe be nice those fatties gotta wear
them
[Laughter]
what I'm saying is it reminds me if
anyone watched the Show Doug you know
with Doug funny he was in a band you
know big and they had these oversized
suits that he wore and that's what he
reminded of because I feel like that guy
could go go down like he was uh Dana
Carvey in uh in the one movie where he
plays the the turtle the turtle and he
just goes underneath I just feel like
that's how much room is in there he
could go hide and slink away when things
get tough speaking of body shaming one
more thing before we leave go ahead go
ahead text ball I was in no way
insinuating you were making fun of fat
people
wait wait wait wait no don't get out of
yourself don't get out of yourself I'm
gonna body shame it Jason Aldean don't
get ahead of yourself Texas pole I'm
totally gonna body shame Jason Aldean
right here um Liam Nissan says when
Jason Aldean said try it in the small
town he meant the onion rings this is
Jason Aldean folks
uh let me tell you something he's not
[__] sex symbol Jason Aldean I'm just
saying damn look at that sun tattoo
listen I got a cheese curd I got a
cheese curd bod too at Jason just don't
act like you're some kind of [__]
American sex symbol that's all I ask for
and everyone I'm asking you to go to
realtexaspall.com that's
realtexaspaul.com he's gotta show all
the links are there go to patreon.com I
am Gabe Sanchez make sure make sure that
you're supporting Gabe get ready I'm
about to drag Ben Shapiro and he's in
public into the [__] mind over this
Barbie movie ax excellent excellent we
get more Barbie content then and also
while you're on patreon.com follow my
page at the Tony Michaels just go to
patreon.com Michaels we're gonna do a
phone the bonehead uh right after this
uh at this show I'm gonna take a quick
break and then I'll do a phone button so
pay attention to the patreon page also
don't forget when you're leaving
subscribe to the Tony Michaels podcast
and like the show today hit that like
button download every single episode on
Apple Spotify and Google cool also you
can watch it on Facebook at the Tony
Michaels follow us there follow us on
Twitch it's free at twitch.tv Tony
Michaels tomorrow's Wednesday tomorrow
is Wednesday come back and see us same
time same place
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon